I'm art learn alam I'm a seismologist at
the lamont-doherty Earth Observatory of
Columbia University I'm also associate
director for the division of seismology
geology and tectonic physics
earthquakes and the earth there are two
parts of seismology one is to actually
look in detail at the earthquakes
themselves and the other is to use the
earthquakes is a sort of light source
for photographing or imaging the earth
imaging the earth is something that we
sometimes call structural seismology but
very much like a cat scan you might get
in a medical office we use the waves
generated by earthquakes to illuminate
this internal structure of the earth one
of the great mysteries of the planet is
what is the earth made out of how does
that stuff move and seismology is really
a remote sensing tool for us to try to
understand that
but one of one of the wonderful things
that has happened in the earth sciences
over the last 40 years is what we call
the theory of plate tectonics and plate
tectonics really is a very descriptive
working hypothesis that allows us to
take diverse sets of observations and
put them together and see if we can
understand how the how the planet as a
whole works but plate tectonics really
is just a kinematic theory what that
means is that it really only describes
the motions of the plates how fast they
move what their boundaries look like and
so on but we really don't know how they
move or what forces them to move and to
do that we really have to penetrate into
the interior of the earth now in many
ways the earth is like a big bubbling
pot of thick soup on geologic time the
earth is really a fluid of course on
human time it's a rock you hit a rock
with a hammer at my crumble and break
but on geologic time the earth really
behaves like a big melted plastic ball
and it's the movement of that molten
material that plastic that warm plastic
material that really drives the plates
but we can't observe it directly and so
we use earthquakes and and what we call
structural seismology to image it you
know if you were taking or if you were
interested in the workings of the human
body what you would do would be to take
cat-scans or three-dimensional images
from time to time to time to get sort of
a movie of how the body works well
that's exactly what we're doing with
seismology we take cat-scans time time
time and it gives us some indication of
what's going on of course we can't do
our experiments in geologic time would
just take too long so we use proxies to
let us attain kind of a movie
representation it's something that we
sometimes call 4d seismology
well 40 seismology really means that
we're looking at the earth and three
dimensions up down north south east west
the three physical dimensions of our
real world and sort of getting a time
history geologic time occurs over
millions of years so we you know in the
lifetime of a single scientist you can't
observe that but over the years we've
developed proxies to replace that and we
can use seismology we can use petrology
the study of rocks we can look at the
ages of rocks and various ways we can
even use paleontology the study of
fossils to get some indication of what
the history of the earth looks like but
the you know the real incredible thing
that has happened is that the
three-dimensional aspect of that problem
has really just exploded in the last
decade or so you know seismic
instrumentation used to be pen and paper
used to have these rotating drums with a
pen that would wiggle every time an
earthquake wave past for example but
right now we've course record that
digitally that's like the move from
analog tape to two CDs or DVDs so that's
one element but the other is that you
know we used to have to wait for an
earthquake and we didn't have very many
instruments in the ground just a couple
of hundred but now we can put thousands
of instruments into the ground and so we
get a much finer picture much more
highly result pictures like as if you we
had been shooting through cheesecloth or
a gauze or vaseline or something like
that we we've never been able to really
see the earth and all its clarity and
now we can we're part of a project
called Earth scope for example which is
like a giant high resolution telescope
not pointed to the universe but pointed
down into the earth we know less about
the earth really then we know about the
universe at this point but this
telescope is just giving us fantastic
images we're starting off with the North
American continent and our hope is that
over the next decades will be doing that
around the earth as well
well earthquakes are a weird kind of
phenomenon in the following sense when
we talk about the theory of plate
tectonics the the working hypothesis is
that it's a smooth motion of the plates
that the plates move over geologic time
with predictable rates it's as if
they're kind of a slow movement of
traffic if you will everybody sort of
moving at a rate that stays constant in
time but obviously earthquakes happen
earthquakes predominantly occur where
the plates interact with one another
along what we call plate boundaries
obviously sometimes those plate
boundaries are sideways like we have in
the San Andreas Fault or in the
earthquake that happened in Haiti
sometimes those boundaries are
compressional like what happened in
Chile or what might happen off the coast
of Seattle and sometimes those
boundaries are what we call extensional
the best example of this would be the
Basin and Range in the western united
states around the longitude of salt lake
city going all the way west to the
Sierra so those three type of boundaries
or describe what how the plates inter
interact but earthquakes of course not a
continuous process by any means they're
really what we call a stick slip process
so while the hypothesis of plate
tectonics so the working model is that
the plates move at a relatively constant
rate at the boundaries they stick and
they slip the boundaries don't move at a
relatively constant rate instead the
boundary stick and when they stick the
movement of the plates stresses that
boundary and eventually that stress
overcomes the strength of that boundary
and it breaks and that breakage is an
earthquake that's sort of our what we
call a stick slip model or we have other
names for it but that's basically what
happens the problem that we face as
earthquakes seismologists is that
sticking and slipping is almost a
chaotic process not quite but almost and
so it's very difficult to predict on a
day to day basis over geologic time of
course it's very predictable we can get
an idea of where the active plate
boundaries are
those plate boundaries of course are
major faults in the earth and we know
where the earthquakes will occur but
because we can't predict the stick and
slip cycle very well of certainly over
human timescales we can't really get
what we call a prediction but there's a
deeper understanding of it that that
allows us to forecast instead of predict
and by forecast I mean well first of all
we know where they occur because we know
what the plate boundaries are but we can
get a sense of what the probability of
an earthquake might be in two ways one
by looking at the past history and if we
have enough earthquakes we can sort of
get a statistical model of when and
earthquakes might occur that gives us
some probability and the other is to
actually do a bit of forward modeling
and actually take the plate motions take
a model of of the friction alone the
plate boundary take a model of how the
stress builds up and sort of predict
when and where or I should say forecast
when the next earthquake might occur and
it's gotten to the point where we can
probably do that over the span of a
decade or two perhaps thirty years to
the extent that we can sort of provide
an actuarial table if you want to go out
and buy insurance in California as a
matter of fact there is such an
actuarial table to help you determine
what your rates are or i should say help
the insurance companies determine what
they're going to charge you of course we
didn't have that for haiti we had barely
had that for Chile but the pointers were
getting better at it so you know one of
the exciting parts of earthquake
seismology is that the better we get at
forecasting earthquakes the closer we
might actually come to a prediction that
is useful on human timescales
well they're unusual in the sense that
statistically it's unusual could say
it's just a statistical anomaly
statistical fluke there's no reason to
think that earthquakes are occurring any
more frequently now than then they
occurred last year or 10 years ago or 10
years into the future there's no reason
to believe that and it has nothing to do
with global warming believe me that's a
question that we often get
one of the things we
colleges is that earthquakes occurred
any time in any place is that they don't
even have to occur plate boundaries for
that matter but that's that's a whole
other topic but along some of the major
plate boundaries like the Pacific
Northwest we have evidence of past
earthquakes and that's actually isn't
it's an interesting thing obviously we
didn't have instruments going back more
than about 100 years or so so we don't
have an instrumental record but we have
a record from newspaper all newspapers
for example we have a record from some
old mission records particularly in
California Spanish mission records in
elsewhere throughout the Western
Hemisphere we have very long historical
records in china and japan and in parts
of asia where people have been writing
things down for quite a few centuries
but in some places we simply don't have
that written record and we have to rely
again on proxies there are a couple of
things we can do in a place like
california or seattle let's take
california first one thing we can do
when we have a fault like the San
Andreas is to actually dig a trench
across that fault and when we trench
across faults like that and you do that
trenching it at different places you can
actually see in the disturbed soil the
record of past earthquakes it may occur
every 150 or 200 or three or four
hundred years but with very good carbon
dating or other geological techniques we
can get a good sense of what that
history is and by doing that trenching
at various places along the fault we can
even get a an estimate of the the size
of the rupture which gives us a way to
calculate the magnitude that then allows
us to calculate the repeat interval say
for these very large earthquakes in
Seattle wrote i should say more
generally off the call of coast of
British Columbia of Washington and
Oregon going down into Northern
California that's a different kind of a
plate boundary it's what we call a
subduction zone it's a convergent
boundary it creates the Cascades and the
volcanoes so we can't trench it but what
we can do is look at the history of
uplift on the coast because every time
an earthquake occurs the
upper plate which is basically the coast
of Washington and Oregon and Northern
California gets bumped up a little bit
and by looking at the sedimentary record
actually sometimes can go down as well
but you know looking at the sedimentary
record looking at the way say even trees
are drowned by encroaching water or
lifted above the water table or so on
you can get a sense of the history
people who look at things like tree
rings or the history of corals ornate
corals up there now but if we go
elsewhere around the world we see that
these are all proxies for past big
earthquakes there's another proxy which
in particular for the Pacific Northwest
works and that is earthquakes along that
boundary have a tendency to generate a
tsunami and when it's tsunami propagates
move or moves across the Pacific Ocean
particularly a big one when it hits
islands on the other side of the Pacific
you get what's called tsunami deposits
it's a it's a very turbulent phenomena
brings up pebbles and rocks and disturbs
the beaches and you can detect some of
those but in particularly for the
through the particular case of the
Pacific Northwest around 1700 actually
in 1700 a tsunami was generated it was
recorded in Japan and by looking at the
tsunami records in Japan both the
historical record and the actual
geologic record of the tsunami modelers
have been able to kind of back project
that go backwards across the Pacific
show that the source of that tsunami was
in fact the Pacific Northwest and get a
good date 1700 for that event that event
looks like to be about a magnitude nine
nine and a half that's bigger than what
we had in Chile last just a few weeks
ago and it's about as big as a biggest
earthquake we've recorded instrumentally
so now that we know that that boundary
can support a monstrous earthquake of
magnitude nine we can go about the job
of measuring the
the plates are converging making some
assumptions about how stress is building
up and come up with some sense of what
the repeat interval might be for that
earthquake and sad to say we're pretty
close to the repeat interval for that
earthquake so that's a forecast it's not
a prediction it's a forecast and
thankfully at least the United States
going back a decade or more Seattle an
Oregon have been well aware of the
potential for that earthquake and
they're taking the appropriate steps one
would say to try to mitigate the
potential damage
you know we do talk about things like
the big one when it occur how big it
will be what the impact will be you know
a curious thing by the way is that it we
are getting better at predicting the
impact of an earthquake than we are at
actually predicting an earthquake now
once we know that once we have a
scenario earthquake for example of a
certain size a certain location our
computer modeling really is very good so
we can actually with a computer generate
the possible ground motion from a
scenario earthquake we know how
buildings interact with the ground what
will cause a building to fall down we
even have a reasonable estimates of the
casualties that might arise and the
economic damage as well so we're getting
very good at predicting to damage and
we've constructed such a scenario for
California and the reason for that is
that over the next few decades 30 to 50
years the chance of having a major
earthquake in California is pretty close
to one pretty close to unity in some
sense it's really safe for a
seismologist to say that because source
quakes happen almost certainly a large
earthquake is going to happen in
California so I'm you know I'm not
sticking my neck out by saying there's a
good chance of an earthquake happening
but the question is how where it'll be
and how big it will be and that we base
on trenching we base on base it on very
fine measurements of the crust movie we
have better calibrated models of the
false and the frictions on the faults
and so we're coming up with a sort of a
community understanding of what the big
one might be the US Geological Survey an
academic resource called the Southern
California earthquake Center which
actually involves seismologists from all
over the US if not the globe I've come
together with a consensus statement a
California rupture forecast does it work
and the two areas that are potentially
very dangerous are a repeat of a major
earthquake along the southern San
Andreas east of Los Angeles but
close enough to do considerable damage
to Los Angeles and of course in the
inland empire east basically along i-10
and going down toward Palm Springs
there's a good chance of significant
damage and significant casualties there
the second area is up in the east bay
not a repeat of the 1906 earthquake
which is onda which was on this the San
Francisco Peninsula but in the East Bay
along something called the Hayward Fault
really far the San Andreas system but a
separate fault that's the fault that
colloquially you may remember sort of
runs right through the Berkeley football
stadium the hills above Berkeley and so
on so you know Cal might have difficulty
fielding a football team if that
earthquake occurs but our predictions of
damage they are pretty severe as well
but again you know a knowledge of what
might happen and particularly the damage
that might happen goes a great way to
providing the political will and in fact
the funding to do something about it
can't stop it can't stop an earthquake
but you can build strong buildings you
can prepare the population you can make
people aware of what they might do when
they feel an earthquake in there are
other steps we can take as well now we
can't predict we're getting better at
forecasting but there's also something
interesting called earthquake early
warning systems and this is something
that has taken a while to develop but
when you think about it is kind of
obvious and let me start with the
following analogy earthquake waves that
it I earthquake occurs it generates
ground motion that ground motion leaves
the earthquake so on the rupture zone in
a series of waves and there are several
types of waves and they will move at
different speeds we've you know some of
our students learn that these are
primary secondary surface waves and so
on and the primary words are very fast
secondary waves or slower and the
surface waves are slower still what's
interesting about that that progression
is that the primary waves though fast
aren't very large the secondary waves
are slower but larger and the surface
waves slower still our largest ill and
so it's large ways to do most of the
damage
so the theory is that if you could
detect that little bit of a p-wave
coming along it's not going to do a lot
of damage but it might give you enough
time ranging from a few seconds few tens
of seconds to maybe even close to a
minute or so or more it might give you
enough time to do the sort of things
that would save people save structures
you can stop trains you can shut off gas
you could get people to find safe haven
inside the buildings for example if you
could do that that would constitute a
pretty decent early warning system and
so there are experiments I'm trying to
do that it's been implemented in Japan
it's been implemented in Taiwan and
there are other countries around trying
to to investigate these systems
you know preparing for
quake is multi-faceted multi-dimensional
and the first thing really is being
aware yes I said that earthquakes occur
anywhere but they're more likely some
places than others so you know basic
awareness of where your house where you
work where you are relative to the
faults that might cause an earthquake
that's a matter of public education but
once you know what your risk might be
you have to make some sort of personal
judgment or if you're a government some
sort of social judgment about the level
of risk that you're willing to accept it
is going to be and if you're willing to
accept or only willing to accept a low
level of risk then there are number of
things you need to do you need to ensure
that major infrastructure is resilient
that our water lines our power lines are
built in such a way so that they won't
break that bridges and highways won't
fall down that fire stations will remain
standing so that the fire personnel can
respond and that hospitals remain
standing with respect to individuals in
their homes if you're an earthquake zone
ensuring that your building is up to
code if a code exists ensuring that you
follow that code and even little things
like keeping the knickknacks away from
the edge of the shelf keeping your
dishes way back those are the sorts of
things that can make the difference
between sort of ho-hum boy was at an
interesting event to something that was
a disaster and these are all written
down you can go to the FEMA websites
USGS websites or a whole list of these
things the problem arises when first you
don't have building codes or those codes
aren't enforced that was a situation
Haiti where you don't have the national
or social wealth to actually consider
this something you can do I mean there
be and I don't mean to bring up Haiti
constantly but the issue there was that
there were Sunni sort of day-to-day
problems facing Haiti Culture and Haiti
government that something that might
happen
really can't get on the radar screen and
you could argue the right or wrong to
that but that basically is a situation
and sad to say that's tapped us
throughout the world so you know that
the basic things are really quite easy
to do if you've got the money to do them
and if you get the public awareness to
do them and if you've got the political
will to do them if you're dealing with
the Commons if you're dealing with
infrastructure where you don't have the
political will or the wealth there are a
number of things that the community is
trying to do there's a lot of
concentration on building small-scale
community awareness so that the
awareness of disaster the awareness of
potential disaster i should say occurs
almost at the household level and
enabling people to make decisions but
also giving them sort of the simple
things that they that they could do on a
day-to-day basis not just for
earthquakes but for floods for
landslides and for that matter for
longer-term issues like sea level rise
and climate change you know one of the
one of the key things that we're doing
at our institute and elsewhere is trying
to to bring the knowledge we have about
Earth processes you're so dynamic planet
it's fun to look at we enjoy doing that
but it affects people and one of the
things we're trying to do is to bring
that knowledge not just throw it over
the fence so that policymakers can use
it because you know there's none of a
feedback in that kind of a system we
really scientists need to understand
social and cultural constraints on using
the information and in fact even the
utility of the information that they
provide and if I may say I think the
social scientists and governments and
NGOs need to know what they don't know
and that's a difficult task but to be
honest it's an interesting and important
thing to do and we're getting better at
it
Oh surely is a particularly interesting
earthquake from a seismological point of
view of personal its course is very
large a magnitude 8.8 so we would call a
great earthquake where we use great in
terms of the wow factor if you will it
did kill seven hundred people there
abouts it caused billions tens of
billions of dollars worth of damage so
the economic impact on shalay is going
to be severe but we don't get a
magnitude 8.8 very often the only reason
by the way there weren't more casualties
in Chile and more damage in Chile is
that the earthquake was off the coast it
was in the subduction zone it generated
tsunami as we saw but it wasn't a direct
hit but being anywhere close to an eight
point eight is enough of a hit to be
dangerous and that's what happened in
Chile but it was the result of
subduction zone it's part of what
seismologists call the circum pacific
seismic belt or earthquake belt so
what's colloquially known as the Pacific
Ring of Fire that's actually a great
name because indeed the Pacific is
rimmed is rigged by these subduction
zones when a subduction zone means that
the heavier denser crust of the pacific
ocean basin is essentially diving under
the lighter less dense crust of the
continents surrounding and as it dives
underneath it it sticks and slips and
causes earthquakes you know roughly
seventy or eighty percent of the world's
biggest earthquakes occur in the Pacific
Ring of Fire as a gigantic source of
tectonic energy of earthquake energy the
other interesting thing about that by
the way and the reason it's called the
Ring of Fire is because as these plates
dive down underneath the lighter
continent pieces of them melt and that
melt becomes magma that just drives up
through what we call the mantle and the
crust and creates volcanoes so it's kind
of part of a ecological recycling
mechanism going on you're taking old
crust throwing it out sending it down
the subduction zone recycling it into
new material just like you throw a paper
bag into the garbage or in the recycling
bin
so that's the basics of the tectonic
activity these are quakes tend to be
very large because these are large
plates the continents present a
significant barrier to subduction in
many cases and it takes a long time for
stress to build up one interesting thing
is that we knew about this this problem
in Chile of course for a long time and
of course the chileans who have an
extraordinarily advanced in professional
capacity to deal with earthquakes knew
about this as well but 20 or 30 years
ago using very simple components of the
plate tectonic theory this particular
area was identified as a so called
seismic gap a place where an earthquake
was basically overdue couldn't predict
it but we could forecast it and that's
what in some sense saved Chile
now a large earthquakes do strange
things of course what an earthquake does
is in addition to breaking the ground it
actually moves big crustal blocks around
and when it does that it shifts the
distribution of mass of the earth now
because this wasn't an asteroid or a
comet hitting the earth and causing all
these vibrations the earth has to
conserve its angular momentum and the
way the earth conserves its angular
momentum when crustal blocks shift like
that is to change the rate of rotation
and to slightly shift the axis of
rotation it can be calculated but it
really isn't measurable on the other
hand if you're being paid by the micro
second maybe it's something that you
might worry about but the interesting
thing is that we can calculate it not
that it is in fact something we ought to
worry about
now haiti is a different kind of an
animal but it pays to think about what's
really happening around South America
the Chilean event a subduction event was
a seduction of a piece of the Pacific
plate in this case called the Nazca
plate but a piece of smaller plate going
underneath under the chili underneath
the Pacific Ring of Fire and so this is
a case where the continent and the
Pacific Ocean are sliding are converging
against each other in the Pacific diving
down because it cause it's denser but if
you look at the northern and southern
parts of South America picture in your
mind you've got the Caribbean to the
north of course you got the scotia seid
of the south between South America and
Antarctica and those are two very
interesting plates you know in some
sense you could think about those plates
as resulting from the squirt of material
in geologic time going around South
America so if you can't sub duct this
stuff you can't get everything
underneath South America through
subduction that stuff has to go
someplace and it goes north and south
and sort of squirts around and the
Caribbean plate is one of these plates
that got squirted through the gap
between North and South America of
course it's a vast simplification but
it's actually the way we we teach it
it's kind of a fun thing to think about
and so that the Caribbean is actually
itself a small plate it is a significant
part of plate tectonics it was will
recognize as a plate but it's basically
squirting past South America between
North and South America going from west
to east and it's moving at a little less
than an inch a year relative to North
America now the unfortunate thing for
Haiti is that for geologic reasons Haiti
lies along them that northern boundary
and because this is a squirt boundary
going from west to east that is what we
call a strike-slip fault it's a fault
that moves sideways there are some
complexities to that but that fault was
also recognized as being capable of
supporting a magnet
seven or greater earthquake actually 7.2
in fact that forecast was made in the
professional literature in 2008 two
years ago and and we've known for about
20 years that that fault was dangerous
anyway that wasn't a subduction
earthquake that was a sliding earthquake
and sliding the earthquakes will strike
slip earthquakes are dangerous also for
a number of reasons first of all they
tend not to be as large as a subduction
earthquake but can be large enough they
also in this particular case they
occurred on land and unfortunately they
it was almost a direct hit on
port-au-prince the earthquake itself was
shallow which increases the amount of
vibration that people on the surface
feel and was very close to major
population centers so if you will it was
sort of the perfect storm of bad effect
even if Chile had good building codes
and good construction I think we would
have seen tens of thousands of
casualties anyway very difficult to deal
with an earthquake of that sort but it
was a different kind of an animal we've
looked at the chile earthquake in many
ways and we continue to do so in fact
there are a number of conferences coming
up in the next few days to try to move
to the next phase of chile rebuilding
and sort of essentially make the
rebuilding of chile more risk conscious
not just for earthquakes but for the
storms coming up and the annual storm
season the annual hurricane season and
concomitant landslides and other natural
hazards but you know trying to
understand these earthquakes on land
these strike-slip earthquakes it's a
very complex problem and one of the
things that were very worried about in
haiti is that this earthquake may have
stressed parts of the fault that did not
rupture on january 12th you know when an
earthquake happens it doesn't zip open
the whole fault and only zips open in
this case about a 40 kilometers segment
of it there's still stuff on either side
that did not rupture well
that stuff may have been over stressed
that piece of the fault may have been
over stressed and so the potential for
an earthquake on those segments may
actually have increased that again is a
computer model it's something that we're
working on it is hard to predict but it
is something that as a forecast ought to
play into the way Haiti is being rebuilt
Chile we could do the same thing but to
be honest Chile apart from the economic
damage in the economic recovery Chile
has a good capacity to deal with future
earthquakes and the outcomes of this
earthquake with Haiti I hope that the
international community will work with
the Haitians to build that capacity so
that they can monitor the potential for
these future earthquakes
well you know I'll be
interest when the earthquake happens and
so we do our best best we can the
questions tend to be repetitive almost
always we get a question from somebody
about whether they can come see the
Richter scale do we have an example of
the Richter scale the Richter scale is
of mathematical calculation in fact
seismologist don't use it anymore the
only reason we give a Richter magnitude
frankly is for the press and the media
but we have much better ways of
measuring the energy of an earthquake
now but the second question that's
cropped up and it's fascinating in its
own right is that the first time I heard
it I thought it was a fluke but I've
heard it so many times since Haiti that
I wonder what's going on that is are
these earthquakes related to global
warming I'm serious about that I'd say
that most of the press and most of the
public that have called in that that
didn't have specific domain knowledge
has asked us that question we also got
questions whether you know 2012 is
coming a couple years early we get that
sort of thing it's just the end of days
but I think it speaks to something more
interesting which is that earthquakes
and major disasters I have a certain
impact on the public consciousness and I
think earthquakes more so or even
volcanic eruptions more so than than
anything else you know we get a major
hurricane a few major hurricanes every
year we get floods every year there are
major disasters that caused an enormous
amount of economic damage and casualties
but yet we hear about them relatively
often and so we kind of think of that as
kind of background this is what the
earth is doing to us but earthquakes
especially major ones are relatively
rare we get a few major ones a decade
particularly ones with huge numbers of
casualties and and the concept of an
earthquake that it shakes the firmament
that that that it removes your footing
that it could destroy everything in a
blink of an eye and that it is
unpredictable that it just happens
even if your rationale in a scientific
way even if you're rational and even a
theological sort of way you get a it has
to have some impact you know the the
response the scientific response to the
chile earthquake although modulated a
bit by the damage and by the casualties
still was this is a major earthquake
we've got to look at this as well as we
can because we only get a couple of
shots a decade to look at this so now
there are teams of scientists and lots
of instrumentation going to Chile but
when you get down to Haiti or something
like Haiti when you get a directed on a
capital city when the the bulk of the
nation is affected where you have damage
that far exceeds their economic ability
to to come back coupled with the fact
that an earthquake literally moves the
ground on which your cited you start
asking basic questions like should I
even be here should I be living here do
I have to move what is what is the
future of my country what is the future
of my city and those are sorts of
questions I things have such a big
impact on the public that by necessity I
think we've got to talk about them we've
got to talk about what it means I think
science is somewhat ill equipped to do
that we we quantify everything we
enumerate the energies the displacements
the ground motion we have we have
technology and we have lingo but none of
this relates to somebody who's asking
the question my house was destroyed
where should I move it relates of course
in a very quantitative scientific way
but how do you how do you approach that
person how do you assure them that the
situation has a rational response now I
don't think we have a good way to deal
with that so a lot of the questions we
were getting and a lot of the thinking
that generated
I had to do with the central questions
of what does this mean particularly for
the future of Haiti but what does this
mean when we talk about taking steps to
mitigate against future tragedy future
disasters not just for earthquakes what
for the other major natural disasters as
well and to me that and to many of us i
should say it's not that we haven't
thought about this before but it seems
to me to be an area not just a research
but of so sort of a way to link directly
to the public directly to the people who
need to understand what it is we're
doing as scientists and I could I can
make the same sort of Argan about
climate change for example but the
earthquakes serve I use a phrase and I
don't mean to use it lightly but
earthquake service training days for the
major environmental disasters major
environmental stresses that our planet
faces and if we can begin to address how
we relate to the public how we provide
assurance how we help the public to
understand what it is it happening them
if we can understand how to do that for
major earthquakes or major hurricanes
then perhaps we can do something about
stuff that's even more merger the major
more in the future more emergent more
probabilistic where we actually might
have a chance in modifying our behavior
to do something about it so what I've
taken away from this interaction from
Haiti and it's and Chile and I must
admit it's not new to this earthquake
we've had it before with the univision
earthquake in the indian ocean tsunami
we've seen it earthquakes going as far
back as the 80s and the 70s and places
like Armenia and China and so on but
what we've taken away from this is that
there's a conversation that scientists
have to have with the public that the
public will regard as deeply meaningful
which means
we can't just throw our results over the
fence we can't just stick with our
technical journals there's got to be
some other mechanism and in my view I
think universities where we ascribe to
liberal thinking the small L liberal you
know we ought to that ought to be a good
place to do it and i think the
universities have that kind of role to
play beyond the roles that governments
and other social institutions play
yeah I did you know it's the rare
seismologist who hasn't experienced an
earthquake we call them theoreticians by
the way but yeah I've experienced
earthquakes nothing larger than about a
magnitude 6 and of course I've been in
aftershock zones where magnitude fours
and fives are fairly fairly frequent I
and you take steps to deal with it but
it's very difficult for me to imagine
what it would be like in an 8.8 I mean
we or even a seven-point oh that was a
direct hit I personally feel fortunate
that I haven't been in that and I
sometimes joke with my colleagues that's
why I work in New York and not in
California but on the other hand you
know at we understand earthquakes in the
abstract and the visceral feel of an
earthquake is something that perhaps
might contribute to the conversation we
need to have with the public and maybe
there ought to be a program to get a lot
of seismologists into earthquake zone so
that they can understand what it's like
I'm only half of CSIS there but to
experience an earthquake is to know what
it means to somebody who may not be a
seismologist who has a house that's just
been destroyed who has a livelihood that
has disappeared and has a government
that's in shambles and maybe all we can
do is extrapolate but i think it's it's
something necessary to think about